I've thought a lot about what it means
to let you two undergraduates one of the
reasons I've thought a lot about it was
that the most inspiring teachers I had
as a student were three lectures and as
I become at both at Yale and at MIT I
taught lecture courses and I became I
think good good at them although I was
never as good as I wanted to be and I
think well maybe one thing that made me
a good lecturer was I was always nervous
and even to this day I've been lecturing
in the in the film course now I think 38
or 39 years I still get stage fright but
I'm glad I do it because it makes me
live for the students I hated bad
lectures I thought they were the the
pits of Higher Education and I swore to
myself that if I became a lecturer I
would never wore my students that that
was a worse sin than almost any other a
teacher could commit was to be boring
and I have also felt that in recent
years especially although it's always
been an undercurrent in education
there's been a kind of growing negative
feeling about lectures as if they're
they're hurting students into a herd
experience and it doesn't give them
hands-on experience and I think
intellectually that's a foolish
perspective professors know more than
students it's appropriate for students
to listen to professors sometime
professors should take the
responsibility of taught when they talk
to students very seriously if they can
present the information to students in
ways that are more effective on paper or
on film or in some other format they on
video discs or on computer discs they
should do so but if they take and in the
in a small classroom they should
certainly encourage discussion and
interaction but I think surely there are
times and places especially in the
humanities when it's perfectly
appropriate for a professor who knows an
immense amount more than the students to
present material that has been
synthesized by the years of study and
understanding that he or she has
and it's and the greatest experience is
the most inspiring intellectual
experiences I had as an undergraduate in
college were from lecturers and I taught
I was very fortunate I went to a
wonderful University Princeton they had
very small classes I was in some
tutorials that could they were called
precept Orioles that were seven students
and a full professor so I got the
benefits of intense one-on-one or close
to one-on-one attention and I loved
those classes but the classes I had in
which there were a hundred or
seventy-five or a hundred and fifty
students listening to a professor of
history or a professor of philosophy or
a professor of literature talk in the
ways they did about ideas about the
history of ideas about the power of
texts taught me what literature is and
taught me what intellectual engagement
with literature should be and I swore to
myself that if I became a teacher I
would try to be a good lecturer rather
than a bad one so so it seemed to me as
I first of all as I thought about the
most inspiring lectures that I had as an
undergraduate there was one professor I
had especially he's now dead but he was
a wonderfully inspiring man also became
an inspiring scholar who who didn't
produce a lot of work but his
scholarship was very productive and he
was a department chair who generated a
lot of colleagues work he was a great
man his name was Lawrence Holland and he
was his book was called was on Henry
James was called the expense of spirit
his lecture was on American literature
and the number of us in that course
became professors of literature I read
thinking now who I've stayed in touch
with them they and they're also teaching
or still still teaching around the
country so Holland affected other
students as well as me and his strategy
in lectures I've tried to copy or even
plagiarize one thing he always did was
he presented an outline it wasn't it was
not the text of the lecture but it was
three or four central digestible points
that organized the lecture in sequence
he would give out a mimeograph
to each of his students and you would
you would follow along and sometimes
under each rubric there might be one or
two other sub facts to help the student
it didn't capture the whole lecture but
if you could use that sheet to organize
your understanding of the lecture I
thought that was a wonderfully helpful I
found it wonderfully helpful but the
both for review but also because what it
showed me was that Professor Holland had
planned what he was doing that he was
presenting material to me that he had
thought long about that he had organized
in a serious way but the second great
thing about Larry Holland's lectures was
that they were not completely written
out there were parts of them that were
written out very eloquent moments often
at the beginning at the end and I've
sometimes imitated that but the greatest
part of his lectures with his lecture
seemed spontaneous
even though he was following his lecture
it seemed as if he was not he was
speaking to me and I tried to capture
I've never been as good as he was
another professor who did this but who
read his lectures and was theatrically
very powerful taught with me at Yale and
it was Bart Giamatti the man who became
the president of the of baseball the
president at first the president of the
American League and then the
Commissioner of baseball and when he was
a great teacher too and a great lecturer
but he wrote most of his out and he used
to practice his readings and I felt even
though his lectures were great that they
didn't match what Holland did my my
undergraduate mentor because Holland
seemed really to be talking to me and
yet when I as a student looked at his
outline I realized that he had given me
a brilliantly coherent that was my ideal
I'm not sure I actually fully ever
realized the idea and that may be part
of the cost you pay for not writing it
out because what has happened I mean I
always give an outline to my students
and I try to follow the outline but I
also try to Leafs and I also plan and I
pick my details in there when I'm
lecturing in the film course I create
clips that I show that and I'm you know
I've sort of planned when I want to use
the clips and they interrupt them the
flow of my discourse so this first
sequence it comes from cops and in many
ways I think it embodies that kind of
a version of the trajectory or crescendo
joke I was talking about earlier it's a
small version of the cannon joke that
you see in or jokes plural because
there's another joke with the cannon in
the second half of the film that that
I've talked about earlier let's show it
great and of course this is the moment
where Keaton is in flight from the
police the cops are chasing me runs up
this teeter-totter right here he gets he
runs up a ladder and turns out to be a
like a like a seesaw but when I am at my
best I think I'm doing something that
then that can't be captured in printed
form or couldn't be captured if you gave
students a transcript of what you had
done which is that I'm modeling thinking
I'm modeling how you make connections
I'm even modeling discovery in a certain
way because by not intellectual
discovery because by not actually
writing the words out I sometimes bring
the material together in a different way
and I do make discoveries while I'm
talking and that energizes me and makes
me more powerful and I think and that
was another thing that I got from Larry
Holland I realized that the another
aspect of what he was showing me was how
not just intellectually engaged but how
passionately engaged how emotionally
valuable studying literature could be
and I tried in my lectures
not exactly consciously because I think
I absorbed some of this unconscious only
in the recent years that I've thought
about it abstractly and I'm able to
articulate it but I see now that
Lawrence Holland was a great grader
there were other gray I had other great
lecturers at Princeton he wasn't the
only one but Holland was the one I
remember best and I admire and I
sometimes when I remember to do this in
the last lecture of the film course I
pay respects to him I'm getting
sentimental about him I haven't seen him
or talked to him in 3040 years
in a certain sense that what I try to
tell the students about what I do for
the film course is this I want them to
watch they will the movie is the primary
text and I see myself in some sense as
playing the role of a kind of
synthesizer or a channel which tries to
give a kind of brief but extraordinarily
concise account or summary of the best
that has been said about this particular
film or the best that has been said
about the historical processes that lead
up to the making of the film in other
words because I don't expect my students
to become film scholars or literary
scholars right in my literature courses
I have the same ambition I imagine that
I imagine that the kind of student I
want to reach is that of a literate
citizen and I I don't expect them to
have the kind of knowledge that a
scholar would have I try to play the
role of someone who synthesizes aspects
of the scholarship for them and that's
also another reason why the lecture is
more is important because I could have
the students read five scholarly books
and synthesize them but I do that for
them so that they have the time to look
at the film and think about it seriously
the environment of the classroom or the
lecture room is a unique kind of
community it depends on certain kinds of
conventions that everyone accepts for
example in the lecture students know
they're not supposed to raise and
interrupt you in the middle of your
lecture and it's only a very aggressive
or arrogant lecture who a student who
will do so a good lecture will sometimes
say if you have questions I'll make time
at the end or in my classes what I try
to do is say look I'm going to give the
the first 15 minutes of my lecture next
week to questions you might have about
anything and I urge you to bring them up
you need to do that I think if you're
lecturing you shouldn't ever in my
courses of course there's also and I
think this is critical I don't believe
in courses that are only lecture even my
course which has two hours of lecture
week has one hour of discussion
recitation I think it's very important
for the students to take possession of
the ideas that you talk about I think
that students in a good class I think
you do create a kind of community a
community of learning a community of
inquiry it can be especially exciting in
a discussion class where you actually
talk about I try to tell students you
know this is one of the few places in
which you can get angry in a certain way
and passionate in disagreement with
someone and not offend them and and
that's the most exciting kind of class
when you say you know you're completely
wrong about that passage knowing that
the person you're saying that to won't
be offended you're not attacking the
person you're part of the passionate
discourse of trying to understand the
excitement of trying to understand the
text trying to understand what some some
writer or artist has done that can be so
enlivening and it can be it can be truly
a deeply communal experience it doesn't
even work if it's not in some sense
communal so but I think even in a
lecture there's a sense of interaction
between you and your audience and if
your audience is bored if your audience
is not listening if they go online and
start doing their homework right or
living there or there or their email
you're a bad teacher and you shouldn't
be doing it you should be you should if
you if you're arrogant enough to think
that you want the students to pay
attention to you for 50 minutes without
interruption you better be organized and
you better be good
and I think a lot of professors are not
and I and I think that they're that that
they dishonor my profession when they do
that I think III think we should we
shouldn't we shouldn't have lecturers
who don't really do their job properly
but I think lecturers who do do a
uniquely valuable job they model things
for students that they can't get
themselves in discussion they show what
real learning can be and what passionate
engagement with learning can also be and
that's the kind of defense I would give
of of the meet of the medium of the live
lecture